Chris I have good news are you ready for
some good news oh you know it let me
hear it
do you want some good news here's the
good news I spent a lot of time this
weekend trying to answer the fundamental
question of whether or not there will be
an NFL season this year and I was told
and I believe it that there is an
extremely small chance that there will
not be an NFL season extremely small and
I said okay so what is it going to take
to hit that extremely small chance of no
NFL season and basically it would have
to be that the understanding that has
been developed to date regarding the
coronavirus the kovat 19 condition
everything they've learned they would
have to determine that they were
dramatically and fundamentally wrong on
so many of the things they already know
and if they are right about the things
they've learned and so much has been
learned over the last six eight twelve
weeks about this virus and it just
continues to accumulate and it
accumulates quickly out of sight a lot
of stuff happening that we don't know
about we're caught up in the news and
the immediacy and the statements and the
experts and the warnings and the
guidelines a lot of stuff is happening
scientists are making strides behind the
scenes Chris and the big factor is this
the anticipated availability of an
explosion in testing quick and efficient
and easy testing saliva testing not that
gigantic alien probe that has to go up
your nose and scrape the back of your
brain that we've all seen horrific
videos of quick and easy testing quick
and easy results available for everyone
by August I'm told that is where we will
be that there are factories that are
making these things by the millions and
so that's where the good news comes from
because look unless they're gonna do
biodome football where they put
everybody in Florida or Arizona or area
51 or the Antarctic and keep them there
for the full football season you're
gonna have to test every one every day
when they show up at the facility to
make sure they're not positive
it sounds like based on where things are
that's where we'll be by the time
football season rolls around
which makes it even more likely that
they're gonna get the season in so that
was very encouraging to me over the
weekend they gave me a little lift over
the weekend there's still a lot of
concern there's reason to be concerned
there's reason for people who are in the
risk groups to be careful but it looks
like they're gonna be able to pull this
off one way or the other Chris well they
certainly seem they certainly seem
confident you know I know that the
message has not changed from ownership
from the very GetGo
they've been very steadfast on we're
gonna have football in 2020 and I know
that's you know the same themes that are
being pushed to some of my coach friends
throughout the NFL you know they feel
like ownership isn't batting an eye and
they feel like things will be done
within society that are gonna put the
NFL in position to be able to have this
season you know I do hey listen there's
a lot of things that go into this and of
course the testing is the biggest thing
right Mike you know but this is a lot of
money of course to be made or missed
from the NFL
these players being young and what they
look at is being indestructible anyways
I think the majority are gonna want to
play yes there's risk but I think you
know like you said is if we have this
influx of testing that can certainly
make it very very possible and to where
hey yes we're still gonna have to be
careful as a society and the teams and
players will have to be careful too it's
not that you're gonna be able to like oh
you know go to football practice and
leave and go out and party in a room of
thousands of thousands of people and
have fun no you know you're not gonna be
able to do that you're still gonna have
to kind of live life the way we're
living it right now except you might
have just the jurisdiction to go to
practice and be tested and whatever else
and come home if you do go risk you know
going to the bar or go to some club
with a thousand people and the next day
you come in and test positive for copa
19 you're injured you're not playing
this week or we have to quarantine you
and that's how it's gonna go and if
players want to take that risk then
that'll be on there on them to see if
they want to be healthy and be able to
play and contribute to the football team
but isn't that the ultimate incentive to
go home and stay home
because your team is counting on you you
are counting on you you want to play the
idea that every time you show up at the
facility on Monday for film study on
Wednesday Thursday Friday for practice
Saturday for walk through Sunday for
games if you are tested every single
time I don't want to compare this to
marijuana testing but ultimately if you
test positive for marijuana at least
prior to this current CBA enough times
you aren't allowed to play and it
doesn't matter whether it's punitive or
why it's there you don't get to play
period football players want to play so
for the same reasons that guys who were
facing a potential suspension for an
additional marijuana positive would
realize I better be careful I want to
play football that same mindset is gonna
be there all year long I want to play
football it doesn't matter whether or
not I think I could fight off the
coronavirus it doesn't matter whether or
not I think I would be an asymptomatic
carrier of the germ what matters is if
they swab my mouth and they rub it on
the on the little card and it comes back
positive I'm done I'm done for two weeks
three weeks who knows how long that's
the ultimate incentive to get these guys
to go straight home stay home and not go
out and see other people
I agreed it is it's the ultimate
incentive I mean yes and you would hope
that would keep fires on the straight
and narrow let alone you know the human
aspect of it too of course
professionally yeah these guys want to
stay healthy and play and you know put
good film out there in case they're a
free agent after next year they can
strike it rich and make money that way
so you want to be able to be available
on the field but the other aspect too is
you know do you really want to be that
jerk in the locker room ooh did go to
the club but now oh comes in and you
know puts people at risk whether that's
older coaches on the coaching staff or
older men that are in the front office
or anybody else you're just you're gonna
be endangering people that way too so I
think between the ability to play and
the fact of you don't want to be the
jerk that brings it into some you
facility organization or endanger
anybody in your family or professionally
I would think that leads to players
being very strict and making this happen
I'm hopeful I really in you know again
I'm just I know things aren't gonna be
normal by the time September comes
around but I just want us to keep you
know going in that direction and I do
think watching football will be a great
stress relief band-aid whatever the hell
you want to call it for our country and
all of us one of the reasons why the NFL
spent so much time and effort and worry
in the concussion litigation was because
the argument was that the NFL had failed
to properly advise players as to the
risks they were taking that it was
covered up it was concealed that it was
hidden from them the exact opposite is
going to be the case as a relates to the
coronavirus the NFL will be very open
very clear in the warnings and older
coaches Chris as you mentioned they'll
be given the option to not coach and the
speculation that I was privy to over the
weekend is that there would be some sort
of compensation for them if they choose
not to accept the risk this is gonna be
a risk that everyone knows about whether
or not you accept that risk is on you
but it's going to be that original
decision recognizing am i over 60 do I
have diabetes do I have other health
conditions that could cause me to be at
risk of a negative outcome and here's
the other thing too the treatment
protocols are going to be much improved
by the time we get to September where
the death rate for Cobra 19 will be
lower than it has been because they are
figuring out every day every hour
different ways to fight this different
ways to treat this and the institutions
that are figuring it out are sharing
that information with other hospitals so
we'll be in a better spot August
September is a long time from now I know
it's gonna come quickly but think of how
much the world's changed since March 11
and it's only May 4 August 1 is a long
long time away and a lots gonna change
between now and then and Chris look
we've assumed that football will happen
in empty stadiums there
confidence that these stadiums will be
open now whether or not they're full is
a different issue but the people who are
young and are confident that they're not
going to suffer a serious outcome
they're gonna be allowed to go to the
games in wall states that will allow
congregations right but you know the
other side of it too is the antibody
testing there will be thousands if not
tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people who
know that they've already had the virus
and their body has fought it off so they
don't have to worry about catching it
that will allow people to say I'm good
to go
regardless of risk factors regardless of
anything I'm good to go I got my
antibody bill of health here and I can
go to football games I can go to
restaurants I can go to club right and
do whatever I've already had it yeah I
mean I I mean we gotta have it we gotta
we need that I mean you know forget
about sports we need it regardless just
to get back to the normal life you know
functions but yes I think if the
antibody test is going around to where
enough people could start to get it
you're right I mean a lot of people are
gonna realize wow I've already had it
okay I'm comfortable going to sit at a
stadium and a mic we're also seeing in
society right now you know again people
weren't hundreds of thousands of people
weren't afraid to go on the beach in
California I'm not so sure they're gonna
feel that much more scared to go to and
do a stadium I understand it's a little
closer quarters but I think there's you
know yeah I think people will be willing
to you know maybe take those type of
chances but hopefully the testing is so
far down the line that we won't have to
worry about stuff quite like that and
really endangering ourselves for you
know a second run at this whole thing
now here's the thing in order to get to
the point where every state and the
governors of those states where the NFL
has stadiums will sign off on this the
start of the season may have to be
delayed that's why they're building in
the possibility of a February 28 Super
Bowl as opposed to February 7 that's why
it's moving in that direction in order
to get 256 games all of which are played
in stadiums that are open we may have to
see
four week shift in the start of the
season I'd be fine with that if that
happens if it means that it's gonna be a
level playing field for every game I you
know I think we need to avoid
competitive imbalance as much as we can
Chris and there's no competitive
imbalance like having to go Seattle in
September with no fans there you know if
let's look at it it's very simple let's
say the 49ers get their trip to Seattle
week two and there's no fans there the
Rams go week 16 and it's full and it's
deafening that is a clear competitive
imbalance as it relates to the 49ers and
the Rams they're playing the Seahawks
under dramatically different
circumstances well yeah you know I think
that fires better be prepared for that
you know it's just it's gonna be one of
those years you're not gonna be able to
use that excuse hopefully they can find
a schedule to where you know teams and a
relative basis how to play home-and-away
games early in the year you know without
crowds the same amount throughout the
league to where one team you know isn't
complaining going you know hey we played
our home games and no fans are here now
late December we got to go to five-game
road trip and play all these road games
you know that yeah that would be a
little unfair certainly you're not gonna
be able to complain about it this year
no one's gonna want to hear about it but
I would think those are the things the
NFL needs to think about a little bit
certainly to keep the competitive
balance there to where yeah one team
isn't swayed to go oh well you know yep
we played five of our road games early
in the year and we didn't have to deal
with any crowd noise and we're oh we're
undefeated on the road you know yeah
that will not be fair for the teams who
maybe have a back loaded schedule to
play on the road and all of a sudden you
you're playing in front of 70 80,000
people and it's a much tougher time as
we know home-field advantage is a real
thing in the NFL which which means again
if they can delay the start of the
season by four weeks and get all of the
games in with stadiums open if that's
what allows someone like Gavin Newsome
the Governor of California to say okay
late September will allow the new
stadium in Englewood to have Rams and
Chargers games will allow the Santa
Clara Stadium to have 49ers games those
are all considerations that could
cause this to be delayed but still to
get the full 16 games in
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports